you've used the term resource-based
filmmaking yeah I i I'm a big fan of
that versus micro-budget no budget low
budget ultra a little bit like budget is
relative to who you are so and within
which context are creating so for you
know the studio system five million
dollars is a low-budget film so I really
think it's it's pointless to talk in
terms of or to label in terms of budget
micro-budget no budget although yeah
even know but I've heard of no budget
films like ten thousand dollars i mean
so I call it resource-based filmmaker
because I think most often when people
mention no budget micro-budget ultra-low
what they're really talking about is
resource-based filmmaking and this is
something I'm really passionate about
like especially right now in my career
for a number of reasons but in a
nutshell what I consider resource-based
filmmaking is rather than allowing your
imagination at the conception level at
the beginning stages of creating a film
or a script writing a script rather than
allowing your imagination to just go
wild you know kind of a story that takes
place during the war of 1812 of you know
about a troop or something you gotta
start with your resources what do I have
access to guaranteed access or near
guarantee my mom's basement I think you
know I may not even be able to get her
living her up to ego but her basement
she doesn't care my best friend's cabin
in the woods you know now those are
physical things maybe my dad is a civil
war gun freak so I got all these Civil
War guns you know talent
what do I have connections who do I have
connections with in terms of talent
including crew they have talented so I
call them kelan do I know a really good
cinematographer do I know really good
sound prison do I know really good sound
designer so the point is you you begin
with your resources including and this
is the big one yourself what is my level
of talent what is my resource as a
filmmaker because chances are if you're
at the beginning stages you probably
couldn't even direct a war of 1812 love
story or something you know so you have
to discover what your box is too in
terms of talent so that to me is
resource-based so if you take your
resources and honest inventory I
literally have a list of locations and
actors and then you will let that to
inspire you so your mom's basement and
your dad civil war collection maybe it's
a heist movie of people that want to get
in their group of guys who you know want
to take a trip to Vegas they have no
money and they hear about the civil war
collection in the basement and it's a
heist movie in the basement with and
they're after the civil war memorabilia
over you know so you get inspired by
your resources that's resource-based
filmmaking now what I'm really
passionate about resource-based
filmmaking is and why I advocated so
much to people is because it enables you
to make your film since i I've lived in
Los Angeles my entire life but since
I've been making films I've been more in
the film community so over the last few
years I've met countless people
including some friends who are still
trying they're waiting on an investor
they're waiting for this actor to read
their script or their manager they're
waiting for this location they're
waiting for this waiting for that
because they wrote elements in
to their script that they have no access
to and I'm sorry but there are no
buddies okay going back to nobody fell
lady they don't have a right to ask for
this they don't have a right to approach
this a lister unless they ate their
their aunt is the a-listers haircuts
stylist or something that you may have a
right but that's what I'm most
passionate about what resources those
based filmmaking is it enables you it
empowers you to make this film because
now you're a film maker not a film
developer or a film waiter you heard a
film maker and that's why I'm really
excited about resource-based for making
that's why I I advise it to to everyone
in terms of resources and specially to
because you have both that left brain
and right brain them so your your gears
or money in some sense how far is
someone's personal resources do they go
and if they don't have those resources
go to they put on a credit card or do
they not yeah I I'm a big fan of marks
collar off he started to no budget film
school he's like a huge champion for
folks like me he's so supportive and
great I'm a big fan of him and his his
rule in the no budget film school which
I let's end it is do not spend your own
money that's his role but he has
confessed that he breaks it every time
because i think that rule you can't you
can't uphold that rule I mean you can
but I don't think you need to so in my
opinion it really comes out to the
person and your loved ones say you're
married you have a partner whatever your
family your parents you just whatever
you responsibly can afford that's it you
know if you know you got a couple
thousand bucks saved or whatever I just
it's just as long as you're being
responsible with your resources but you
know if you spend ten thousand dollars
to make a movie rather than by a car but
you keep bumming off rinds off
as your friend that would annoy me you
know that's not responsible so I would
say whatever you could comfortably spend
but I do believe in spending your own
money definitely not going into debt I
completely disagree with that absolutely
positively disagree with that but if you
do have cash there's nothing wrong that
my wife and I we spent for my feature
film which we recently did we spent
about eight thousand dollars of our own
cash but that was saved up money for
things like this and what about people
spending eight thousand on short so
absolutely this have you at it okay yeah
I disagree with that like I shorts do
not have monetary value they that's a
pretty much effect at best might be like
five hundred bucks to screen it in Italy
or something I the only way it could be
justified is if you make just the most
phenomenal short film and that could
lead to I guess professional advancement
so it's kind of like going to college or
something like that but I'm generally
against it I think it would behoove you
to take that eight thousand dollars and
make something that you could perhaps
capitalize on profit on which would be a
feature film or something a little bit
more significant meaty such as a web
series or you could spend that eight
thousand dollars on just you know like
more along a more of a long-term vision
such as like developing a website for
yourself branding yourself things like
that and then in the meantime making
resource-based films that I'm not a big
fan of a thousand bucks for a short film
I've always been I've never been event I
and I know people have done it and got
them nothing big mistake you could wow
the world with the one minute short film
shot on your loo
ouch you don't need eight thousand
dollars tape wasn't yeah I just don't
you don't need
you